Americans have racked up more credit
card debt than at any time in history
according to Bank of America surpassing
the total amassed in 2008 during the
global financial crisis and we're taking
on all this debt at a time when the
average interest rate on credit cards is
on Pace to hit the highest level on
record I'm going to tell you just how
much more debt households are carrying
why this is happening and explain why
this could be a serious problem for the
economy let's get into it
Bank of America estimates that the
average U.S household was carrying more
than 8 500 in credit card debt as of
July that surpassed the previous record
high set in May 2008 and is more than
one thousand one hundred dollars higher
than the 10-year average the Federal
Reserve found that in the second quarter
credit card balances saw their largest
year-over-year percentage increase in
more than 20 years unpaid balances on
credit cards have grown by over 33
billion dollars a month over the past
six months that's more than double the
pace from 2019. these are all huge
numbers and economists say the biggest
reason for the surge is stubbornly high
inflation I talked to Aditya Bobby Bank
of America's senior U.S and Global
Economist he told me that Rising prices
have been a double-edged sword consumers
are spending more because things cost
more and while higher wages and job
creation help offset some of the pain
from higher prices they also help create
more inflation Buffet adds that b of A's
data show that consumers are actually in
a pretty strong place and they aren't
experiencing liquidity problems meaning
they aren't using credit cards because
they don't have the money they're using
credit cards largely because they're
buying a lot more stuff
but we're starting to reach a point
where this could become a problem as
spending continues to rise but Americans
balance sheets are starting to shrink
we've seen the savings rate fall
significantly in recent months from
almost double the 10-year average as
recently as April 2021 to about half the
10-year average in August that could
become a big problem if millions of
people lose their jobs and that's what
the FED is predicting Bank of America
foresees a U.S recession next year as do
other financial institutions like
Jeffries and organizations like the IMF
and World Bank are warning of a global
recession Americans could then be facing
record high credit card balances with
record high interest rates right as the
economy is slowing down and starts
Contracting we're also seeing credit
card debts spread to younger and less
qualified borrowers Credit Reporting
Agency TransUnion found that in the
second quarter the number of Bank issued
credit cards topped 500 million for the
first time ever with a 32 percent
increase in originations for Gen Z and
the segment of total balances held by
subprime borrowers Rose by 52 percent
the highest growth rate ever right now
U.S employment is rising savings
balances are high and Americans look to
be in pretty good shape but data on
business activity and the housing market
suggests that could be changing the huge
jump in debt and the rising cost of
paying for that debt are definitely
worth watching young ho AKA Jay-Z had
the right idea when he told us in 2006 I
don't buy out the bar I bought the night
spot I got the right stock I got stock
Brokers moving it like white tops
that's all for now see you next time
[Music]